so let's talk about measurements
what are the things that startups should
measure
such an important question it's actually
the first the first conversation we have
with startups when they get into y
combinator
the first time we sit down with them we
say what's your metric because y
combinator runs for three months you
know they get in it's really four months
from the time they get in five months
from the time they get in but
they have demo day at the end of that
when they get up in front of a room full
of very intelligent people
and they show their progress and the
more progress they can show honestly the
better that demo goes and the better
their follow-up conversations go
so
you have to figure it out and it's
different for every company
now there are variations on themes right
there they're basic themes that everyone
looks at
you know if you're a company that should
be generating revenue
your metric is probably revenue if
you're a social product it's probably
users or some function of engagement if
you're a transaction site it's probably
something about the number of
transactions you do or the volume of
transactions which by the way is just a
proxy for revenue because you probably
take a cut of it so it's particular to
different startups i think the critical
thing is to make sure it's the thing
that actually reflects whether or not
you're succeeding as a business and not
what we call vanity metrics you know and
what's the hard part about like setting
the metrics and measuring them
it's
everything right so i think on one level
it's hard to choose you know you start
out as a company and you think to
yourself oh there's all these different
things i want to accomplish right i want
to hire people i want to raise money
raising money by the way probably the
biggest vanity metric of all right
basically meaningless for the success of
your company um except that it gives you
money to achieve the metrics you need so
you know you think that you think that
you want a lot of people you want a lot
of press you want all these things and
they all feel good but they don't
necessarily matter to your business
right so so that's the first part like
ignoring all that vanity is hard
the hardest part though is once you pick
a metric being honest about it and
sticking to it and and
setting you know time frames
for success and for progress that you
actually stick to so we tell companies
that during y columnator they should
grow whatever their metric is between
five and ten percent a week we try to
say go for seven percent a week um if
you do more grade if not not
and that's great for consumer companies
um and if they're if they're sticking to
that
the thing that happens and this is
something that people miss a lot they
say oh all you care about is growth
but
growth isn't a one-dimensional thing
right growth is a function of the fact
that you've done everything else
properly right you built a product that
people want you got it into their hands
you supported it it continues to be
something that they want to use that's
what leads to growth so you can't you
know you can't isolate it
um if you miss it that's when it gets
hard because then you have to be honest
with yourself about why
you missed that goal why you missed your
metric and that'll make you fix your
business